[Musique]
la cuisine centrale de tours est la plus
importante de la région centre val de
loire
elle produit huit mille repas par jour
et alimente toutes les écoles de la
ville c'est là que l'on retrouve 90 y
voilà comme à la maison avec le petit
bouquet garni l'eau qui va bien les
oignons du sel du poivre juste le
produit naturel c'est très bien et ça
donc c'est consommer avec les saucisses
de morteau donc la saucisse de morteau
si une sortie ski j'ai fait d'avoir des
produits comme ça c'est super agréable
en fait ça fait plaisir voilà on sortir
de l'industriel s'est toujours bien
[Musique]
mais tout va de l'ambition la ville
écologiste veut aller plus loin que
l'aloe galim elle mise sur une nouvelle
cuisine centrale pour atteindre les 100%
de fruits et légumes bio locaux entre
ressemblera une cuisine avec une grosse
légume briller une unité de production
qui aura une petite unité de production
pour les crèches pour pouvoir isoler et
réalisée 100% des mixes et maisons pour
les bébés et un atelier pâtisserie
un chantier estimé à 10 millions d'euros
pour offrir à horizon 2024 une cuisine
modèle plus respectueuse de
l'environnement est meilleure pour la
santé des enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sud de la ville c'est l'heure du
déjeuner à l'école jean giraudoux les
lentilles de la maison gibert vont être
servis dans le cadre de la semaine du
goût seront elles justement au goût de
ce jury exigeant
gardien ses meilleurs vols et lentilles
à la cantine ou à la maison mère
l'accord sont parce que
c'est habituel à la con tu devais à la
maison pas trop ça
chaque année
les légumineuses ne sont pourtant pas
facile à faire aimer aux enfants
les stars indétrônable de la cantine
reste la plus chic
et plus généralement la viande qui reste
un aliment incontournable d'un repas à
la française et qui n'est pas exclue de
l'évolution en cours dans la
restauration collective
nous sommes à 40 km au nord de tours
pascal naudin et agriculteurs il fait
partie des premiers à s'être lancé dans
la production d'une nouvelle viande
labellisée la viande le grand bain ça a
commencé au mois de septembre j'avais
trois animaux d'inscrits pour partir
dans le label de grand boeuf un an
qu'une bête charolaise qui est parti et
première semaine de septembre et les
deux autres une charolaise et une
limousine parti il ya une dizaine de
jours ce label a été lancé par la
chambre d'agriculture d'indre et loire
pour répondre à la demande croissante en
viande de qualité
donc l'idée avec ce label en fait ça a
été de construire une filière viande
bovine donc éligible à la loi et galim
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a construit un
label rouge pour qu'ils puissent en fait
être prioritaires pour rentrer en fait
dans la restauration collective
parce qu'elle n'a eu aucune difficulté à
placer trois de ses bêtes dans le label
son exploitation respecter déjà les
critères de bien-être animal requis
pour vous ce label est qu'est-ce qui
vous apporte concrètement
la sécurité financière voilà on a d un
meilleur coup que ce qu'on a pu
connaître l'an dernier dans du marché
traditionnel quoi donc oui si ça se
stein et prochaine on est sur les mêmes
prix c'est très bien l'année prochaine
en tout cas la demande sera bien là 37
collèges quatre communes et 4 ehpad ont
déjà passé commande jusqu'en 2025
[Musique]